[Music]
[Music]
billy eilish stuns with her performance
at the 2022 grammy awards
driving home under the influence
you scared me to death alongside her
brother and collaborator phineas the 20
year old singer belts her track happier
than ever i don't relate to you
[Music]
i don't relate to you no
of course a touching tribute makes this
performance all the more special billy's
t-shirt yeah that's the face of foo
fighters drummer taylor hawkins who died
last month at age 50. while singing her
grammy-nominated song billy points at
her tea made custom by willie chavarria
while billy was nominated for seven
awards for her sophomore album happier
than ever she went home empty-handed
[Music]
[Music]
but safe to say it's been an epic month
for the la native and her big bro after
back-to-back performances at the grammys
and the academy awards last sunday the
duo performed their james bond title
song no time to die
[Music]
there's just no time to die
and they capped off the night by taking
home the oscar for best original song oh
my god
you guys oh my gosh and backstage billy
reflected on her success
i don't know it's just growth and like
aging i think but yeah i'm super happy i
feel so
like i think that i'm i'm just coming
into my um
being aware of what is good and
around me you know i think that
when i'm that young like when you're
that young it's like hard to understand
how big of a deal things are around you
and how
um important things are and you know you
meet a kid like i'll meet people that
are younger than me and be like
wow they have no idea how cool this is
and it's just like they're kids i just
was a kid and i don't i didn't know and
i'm so so thrilled that that growing up
has has uh taught me to just be like
more aware of the greatness around me
you